we have
anthony scaramucci with us right now the
greatest show on turf anthony are you
there
i am i appreciate you including me guys
i'm sorry i'm a couple minutes late
you're not late i already told him i
screwed up i screwed up it's big to be
on with you as you know and uh
i'm listening carefully to the
conversation and i can just give my two
cents the people that don't understand
it they will trade it and the people
that understand it
are going to hold on for dear life
because they recognize that they've got
waterfront property they've got
waterfront irreplaceable digital
property
that's going to appreciate for
generations and so they're not going to
trade it but i think
your point is well taken that there will
be professional traders that that trade
this thing
um and they'll take their profits you
know and even you know my close friend
uh jim cramer
several months ago you may have
remembered this pomp you got him into
bitcoin you helped me get into bitcoin
which i want to thank you for uh but you
know jim said he sold it to pay down his
mortgage that's what old fogies like me
and jim cramer do with money you know
the the mortgage is at 1.8 1.9
and the inflation rate is at 8 but we're
selling we're buying down our mortgages
because that's what our parents told us
to do because they lived through the
depression you know of course it's a new
world now we're going to talk about
bitcoin actually i'm glad that you're
doing this from your office because the
table right behind you is where you and
i first talked about bitcoin so we'll
get to that in a second i'm going to
grab that coffee now that i see them all
right you got the coffee
you got pants
caffeinated you got pants pop and it
looks like i got little pumps
i'm the only baby boomer here you guys i
gotta get ready
starbucks the first question i see in
the chat is do you have pants on
i do i swear to god
because i got a big meeting this
afternoon with one of my clients and i'm
in the office amazing if this was my
home office i'd be wearing my 1981
phys ed champion
phys ed shorts
i'm actually i'm actually in briony
which is a sign of how poor i am
it's only billionaires like you guys
that dress like
are you allowed to curse on this bomb
yeah you can you can say whatever you
want yeah i mean i mean look at the way
you guys dress jesus christ
you know this is a sign that you guys
are billionaires and i'm out here uh you
know slapping for a living
yeah my brother does have sandals on
all right let's talk just kind of macro
environment and kind of monetary policy
uh you said that the inflation rate is
eight percent the fed says that it's 5.4
i tend to think you're closer explain
why you think it's eight and they think
it's five
well i mean the transitory number was
eight uh you know let's give them
whatever they want you wanna say it's
five that's a ridiculous number that
means you're in negative rate territory
in the united states that means you're
in my uh intellectual mentor paul tudor
jones is reporting this morning what you
and i both know the obituary for the 60
40 portfolio has already been written
and now the question is what are we
going to do where are we going to go
and you discovered before i did that
there are digital hard assets
that are going to replace fiat assets
because unfortunately like nakamoto said
11 or 12 years ago
we corrupt those assets and so
you caught me in this room on your
earlier versions of your podcast where
we were talking about the history of
money i wasn't yet in bitcoin but i was
indicating to you why i was moving that
way
because we've now jumped the shark
to use a happy days expression on money
if you've made
and you know these numbers pom because i
follow you on twitter you know you tell
me what's the m2 up 40 40 40 percent
yeah 40 percent
yeah let's just call it 40 for the sake
of this argument okay uh what what what
amount of money's been printed well if
you look through the beige book
uh it was 592 billion dollars at the end
of may
i can only guess because i haven't seen
the recent number but i'm going to say
it's close to
i don't know 650 billion dollars has
been printed by the federal reserve this
year
so that's going to show up in the
inflation data that
that's killing
the people
in our family
that didn't get educated or don't own
bitcoin you know i'm from a family of
immigrants as you know italian
immigrants my dad was a crane operator
a lot of my
contemporaries my cousins are
clamming in oyster bay they're cutting
deli meat they're installing auto glass
they can't catch up with this nonsense
you and i can own assets our assets are
going to appreciate and our standard of
living will be just fine but if you're a
wage holder and the federal reserve is
printing 700 billion dollars of money
you're screwed pom and i and i told you
that when we first met when they broke
the contract with gold in 1971
they slowly eroded middle and lower
middle class living standards and now
we're living in an age of populism uh
economic desperation for a large group
of people which used to be economic
aspiration
and we've weakened the society so when
you see something like bitcoin you're
like oh my god this is a technological
innovation
which can actually be a store of value
for those people
can help the underbanked
and could literally transform the world
and if we get this thing right and it
exponentially networks to the billion
plus users that you and i both think
we'll get to
well then hold on it's going to check
it's going to hand check the bankers the
central bankers they're going to be
forced into a box
of fiscal responsibility and conformity
because if they don't do that there's
another option for human beings
aka bitcoin or you pick one of the other
cryptocurrencies that you like but you
get you get the point that i'm making
for sure and one of the things i don't
think people really appreciate well
there's two points with you right so one
is you're a student of history i
remember when we did the podcast you
laid out the history of money better
than uh anyone i walked out of there and
i said i don't know how that guy
remembers all that information but he's
like an encyclopedia the second thing is
that when you decided to actually enter
the market i believe you guys bought 400
million dollars of bitcoin was kind of
the first foray
you have a very very good memory yeah is
that correct
yes that is correct and so uh we are
sitting on a little over a billion
dollars of bitcoin um to your brother's
comment uh we've had to sell some
because
in our fund now i have a core bitcoin
fund the first trust skybridge bitcoin
fund that's a total hoddling situation
i've got a lot of money in that
personally but in our flagship fund sort
of the nine billion dollars that we're
running
um we started with 400
uh would have loved to have left it but
i can't be in a situation in the
flagship fund where bitcoin is eating up
the whole fund so
i i i took some out of there we sold
some uh uh but we're going to leave it
for right now it may trade back to 50
000. i don't know
what i do know though
is it's likely to get to 150 000 over
the next 12 months i'm going to stick
with my earlier price target that i
shared with you on our salt talk when
you did my podcast i think it's 100 000
by year-end
and i just think it's that because
there's now
a gateway opened guys you know this
anthony a gateway opened yesterday
where an institution can now say i can
buy this
um you know if you're a vaxxer or an
anti-vaxxer some of my friends said well
i'm not getting vaccinated until the fda
approves the vaccine
and so that sort of metaphorically
happened for bitcoin you got an approval
from the sec bitcoin lives
in the financial regulatory ecosystem
and it's not going anywhere and now that
portal has opened for
a sophisticated early adopting
institution to say it's okay for me to
step in the water here i'm not going to
get fired if i own this thing so one of
the things that's really interesting is
that you manage billions of dollars
you've been doing this for quite a long
time very successful at doing so
you
don't normally strike people from the
crypto community as why would anthony
scaramucci and skybridge be
participating here and when i talk to
you i think that you see kind of the
writing on the wall right the world is
shifting to this new digital economy and
it feels like uh based on what i know
that you're taking sky bridge and kind
of slowly starting to say hey look we
want to include this in kind of the
aperture of what we look at is there a
world where sky bridge ever goes all in
on bitcoin cryptocurrencies or do you
think that having a parallel strategy is
kind of the winning strategy and i'm as
in as you can be yeah you know i'm going
to be 58 years old in january i'm pretty
in right i mean i got a billion dollars
of this stuff uh and i've laid in i've
got a a uh etf those are from my
fuddy-duddy friends you remember there's
fudd which is fear uncertainty and doubt
and then you've got fuddy-duddies which
are these old people that won't own
bitcoin i created crypt for them crpt
trades on the new york stock exchange
it's a crypto proxy effectively it's you
know microstrategy and coinbase and
marathon and so it has unbelievable
correlation to bitcoin
um i've raised an ethereum fund i think
you know i have an investment in
algorand which i think is a fascinating
technical property
but i'm all in we've got almost a
billion dollars in bitcoin
i wrote a book
and again anthony this is an
international bestseller
and if you don't believe me you can come
into my warehouse back here at sky
bridge where i've bought every share or
every book to make sure it was
[Laughter]
i mean come on no one's ever bought one
of my books so i'll tell your listeners
uh my email okay okay it's acaramucci at
skybridge.com if you want a copy of the
book you're listening to the pops
podcast i'll mail you one a scaramucci
skybridge.com
it's a short little pamphlet but it'll
explain it to your parents
okay it'll explain to your parents what
it is
and the subtitle is how i stop worrying
about cryptocurrency
and you should too so i'm all in it
it took me longer than you because i'm
an institutionalist i said to you
in our first podcast 100 million wallets
a place where i can store it and not
worry about it because i'm going to be
in deep you know with nine figures if
not 10 figures
and then the third thing is what's the
regulatory landscape is the united
states going to accept this and so last
year
right around this time all three of
those things seemed like they were going
to happen
uh and so then we started buying those
coins
and we're in and i expect our business
to continue to morph into more digital
assets but you asked me a really
good question that i want to answer
how does an old fart like me
see it
and the answer to that is i have to
listen to young farts like the three of
you
and and i think we make a very big
mistake generationally
if we're not listening to each other
like you guys could avail yourself to my
experience dealing with volatile markets
dealing with the ups and downs of
entrepreneurship
the humbling nature of life like if
you're having a bad day think of my ass
getting fired from the white house in
july of 19
you know july of 2017 july 31st as an
example right and so you can learn from
me in terms of how to roll with the
punches and bounce when you need to
but i can learn from you where the
future is going because you and your
team the best business show anthony
pompliano you guys are creating the
future that my children and
grandchildren are going to live in and
if i close my mind to that if i act like
the 97 year old charlie munger and i say
oh it's the worst thing that's ever
happened in civilization
that means i've lost my neuroplasticity
and i've lost my ability to adapt and
learn
so my
message to everybody listening everybody
watching you
we can learn from each other let's not
close our minds and reconfirm our biases
let's open our minds
and let's
test our theories on each other and you
know i i want to say thank you i was
with michael saylor yesterday i thanked
him i want to say thank you to you
um you were very influential in helping
me see what was going on in the
blockchain and and in bitcoin i i
appreciate it you you taught me plenty
don't you worry i i should be thanking
you not me uh not you thanking me talk
to me about institutional interest and
what you're seeing in terms of kind of
your peers or colleagues and what
they're thinking about uh the asset
class
so people get mad at me pomp because
they asked me honestly and i said i
don't see it i've got my my guys out
here said yeah what are you doing why
are you telling people that there's no
interest in the institutional community
and i'm like because i don't see it if i
saw it i would say it i want to be
straight up with people you know and and
i thought there was going to be way more
institutional interest at the beginning
of the year january 2021
than manifest but now i'll make a bold
prediction anthony
i think there's going to be
institutional interest over the next 12
to 18 months because you now have gotten
the regulatory box checked and that
checking of that box is going to lead to
institutions saying hey i got to get in
this thing i've got to own a piece of
this i've got to understand it and what
would george soros say
he would say invest and investigate
later you've heard that aphorism and i
think you're now going to start to see
it but i didn't see it over the last
eight or nine months
and that's just me being straight up
with the ant
how do you think about the etf launch
yesterday it's got 570
million dollars of assets at the end of
the day yesterday did about a billion
dollars in uh you know kind of uh on
market and after hour trading does that
start to signal that there's more
institutional interest or would you be
surprised if there wasn't more than that
so i think two things are happening okay
number one people are wading into the
etf you know it's a futures etf so
there's some issues there i don't want
to bore everybody with the specifics
there but i would prefer a cash spot etf
over futures i understand why gary
gensler when commissioner gensler went
in that direction but there's two things
going on people are buying the etf
but you've got institutions now calling
knighted calling galaxy calling
gemini and and fidelity and saying okay
i want a wallet i want to store some
bitcoin on your premises or coinbase
institutional you know and that's
happening my friends have said to me
where are your coins stored can you
refer me to somebody where they want to
buy the direct coin now
so you've got two things happening
money's flowing into the etf that's
fantastic but money's also flowing into
the asset
directly in the cash market
uh from these institutions
joe john what questions you guys got hey
anthony thanks for doing this and nice
to meet you
was that a pause where you wanted him to
say something
i thought he was the younger pop or the
older pump or the medium
out of us three all right so you're the
you're the mama bear pomp
i don't know if i like that but all
right all right we'll let it slide uh
all right as someone who uh so bitcoin
historically has been a pretty volatile
asset obviously right as someone who has
dealt more with uh maybe traditional
equity markets or things like that and
manages billions of dollars for clients
how do you get individual clients
comfortable with that volatility
um
well you have to size it appropriately
so that's one of my issues in my core
fund if i put a four percent position
and the and it grows to 20
i have to probably scale it back so that
i can calm down my investors uh so what
i tell people if you're a bitcoin
maximus come into my bitcoin fund
if you're in my other fund let me size
it appropriately because it will be
volatile
um but you guys know this and but i
think there's some historical
perspective necessary to share here
all these
medcap law
network effect investments
they start out in the early adoption
phase with mega volatility why
you've got all the fuddy-duddies and the
ancients shorting it disbelieving it
shorting tesla
shorting amazon amazon's going to miss
its number it's 1999. let me short the
goddamn thing
and
they
create the volatility same thing happens
in bitcoin you know we hit an air pocket
uh with elon musk and china bitcoins at
65 000. it's at 29 000. i've got clients
lighting me up
and you guys know this everybody's a
long-term investor until they have
short-term losses when they have
short-term losses they set their hair on
fire they run around in a circle and so
i my one of my jobs is to be the
financial
and psychological coach i've got to tell
people calm down
uh stay the course we have a five-year
plan or a three-year plan
and i'll just point out because i think
it's worth mentioning if you were an
early investor in amazon
you know just think about this for a
second the ipo of amazon may 15 1997
a 10 000 investment is now worth 21
million dollars 21 million 140 000
however you would have had to subject
yourself to eight periods of time where
it dropped at least 50 percent
one period of time where it went down 85
and the barons newspaper had a front
page article amazon.bomb
the age of this internet retailer is
over but the cat that made amazon jeff
bezos
he shot himself into space in his own
rocket
okay so what do you guys want to do do
you want to
be patient
and look at something like bitcoin and
see the exponential growth of wallets
and the scale and understand the value
of the network effect of those
properties associated there with
and stay patient
and watch bitcoin
eclipse gold in terms of its market
capitalization
or do you want to trade it and get juked
out of it at the wrong moment and do
what
non-psychologically minded investors do
is they sell lows and they buy highs
and so to me i got to get in the face i
got to get in i have to grab the face
mask of my clients and pull them close
to me like a good coach and say stop it
get your emotions out of this thing
this is a revolutionary asset this is
digital waterfront property this is
digital energy
that is going to transform the world and
over the blockchain we are going to
de-layer
our society we're going to take
third-party
intermediaries out of the society
there'll be a cost savings it'll be
ecologically friendly
there'll be quantum benefits associated
with this and you can own a piece of
this property today
at a very attractive price this is you
and me pomp going to miami beach in 1921
and buying oceanfront property facts so
i have one more question it sounds you
you mentioned that you think uh bitcoin
is going to overtake gold right so
bitcoin's market cap i believe today is
like one point one one and a quarter
trillion one point two five trillion uh
and gold is around 11 trillion so do you
have any estimates or kind of uh you
know how long you think that might take
to happen
you know it's a very good question i'm
just checking markets right now yep and
you know you know i i would say
realistically
um if you've got in my opinion you've
got to get to a billion wallets
and so
you know
i'll go with kathy wood's estimate kathy
is saying to people end of 2024
mid 2025 you'll be at a billion wallets
and so if you think of the scarcity of
bitcoin
i think it would be worth probably five
or six hundred thousand dollars a coin
by then
and uh
you know
there you go that's where it is by the
way i'm sure you've had sailor on if you
haven't had them on you can get them on
yesterday when i spoke to michael you
know he doesn't think this is a 10
trillion dollar asset he thinks it's a
100 trillion dollar asset he thinks he
thinks this is at least 10 times
more valuable than gold and you know
anthony's heard me say this one of my
saudi friends said to me
uh anthony when people ask you is this
more valuable than gold or not tell them
this story i said what does that shake
he said well right now mbs loves me
but there may come a day where mbs
doesn't love me i have a usb with 200
million dollars of bitcoin and since
this is a family show i won't tell you
where the shakes suggested he was going
to put the bitcoin as he headed for the
yemeni border okay but he can't put 200
million dollars of gold
in the place that he was describing to
me
but he came with bitcoin yeah exactly so
you get you get the point i'm making and
so therefore the technical properties of
bitcoin the network effect is actually
way more valuable than gold
so i'm i'm an institutionalist guys you
guys are younger than me and smarter
than me
i've got to get my clients
over the hump
of owning digital property okay you guys
are already living in that world i've
got to get the 60 year old to say whoa
whoa whoa i've got guys like jamie dimon
telling these people it's worthless you
know and that that's not helping me in
my you know larry think well i'm sort of
siding with jamie dimon
okay but then my attitude is well these
guys obviously haven't done enough
homework because somebody like ray dalio
was a bitcoin skeptic he did the
homework
he's bought bitcoin uh paul tudor jones
a skeptic
bought bitcoin after doing the homework
so i'm just telling people do the
homework you know and if you do the
homework you're going to want to get
long some of this in your portfolio john
yeah anthony thank you for doing this
nice to a nice version of meet you so i
love how you talk about the emotional
side of things when stocks and assets
are going i need i need one of those
hats though but i'm hoping well you know
me that had it it says bitcoin 150 000
but anyway i'm sorry go ahead yeah no
you're good uh yeah when assets are
going up people don't think it's gonna
stop and when they're going down they
say they're never gonna go back up again
so you gotta take the emotional thing
that's why people hire you
um so can you talk about the etf stuff
going on when do you think a spot etf
will be approved do you think only one
will be approved like can you just talk
about the regulations behind all that
and what gary you think is thinking
so
i'm sort of not allowed to talk about it
because i'm in the quiet period because
i have filed okay so what i can say
is uh something i think gary gensler
would appreciate
is
regulatory oversight on
pricing
and the surety and accuracy of pricing
and so as you guys know uh one of the
criteria for etfs is that there really
can't be any pricing manipulation or any
securities in there that a whale can
come in and you know force the thing
down or force it up by reducing supply
and why gary likes the futures market he
was the former chairman of the cftc
bitcoin futures have been around and
regulated by the cftc for many years and
he's confident that you don't have any
of that going on in the futures markets
so it's not to say that
he's not confident about it in the cash
markets but i think he needs to figure
out a way
to have more regulatory oversight over
the cash markets and so
when that actually happens or when that
step takes place in his mind in the
commission's mind
i'm not sure
but if you're asking me do i think it
will happen i do think it will happen
i think gary has signaled to people
that he does not want the united states
to lose its mantle of financial
leadership he doesn't want us
to turn off the best ideas in
fintech and d5 just imagine the united
states
at the turn of the 20th century
saying oh
that combustion engine and that
horseless carriage we're not into that
let's let the europeans build those and
let the asians build those we're going
to stick with the horse and carriages
okay so what i applaud gary gensler in
doing is saying
we're moving into the future we're
probably going to get dragged into the
future by a younger generation of people
and i'm okay with that i just got to
make sure that the pricing mechanisms
are fair and safe and market-based does
that make sense joe yep
mooch i got a question that uh i don't
want to ask you something that you're
not allowed to talk about but uh what's
going on with sovereign wealth funds any
insights that you can share in terms of
it feels like that's the non-regulatory
stuff i can totally all right so it
feels like we had individuals they ran
wall street institutions et cetera then
we started to get the institutions those
institutions where financial
institutions and uh corporations will
public insurance insurance companies
insurance
balance sheets that cohort basis is now
in and getting in uh the last two are
nation states and sovereign wealth funds
uh we know that el salvador is obviously
in there's probably some other countries
the united states doesn't like as much
that are doing things just not
announcing it
the sovereign wealth funds a lot of
people haven't been talking about it's
like what what's your thoughts there or
any insights that you can share
yeah they're coming the sovereign wealth
funds are on the way uh some of them
have already established small stakes in
them uh i'm making a trip uh next week
to the middle east i'll be speaking at
the fii conference in riyadh i have a
whole slate of meetings with different
sovereign wealth funds related to this
topic i think i think that they're
open-minded you know i i will share this
with you i won't i can't give you the
name of the fund but i have one middle
eastern sovereign wealth fund that's a
big investor of mine
and they really wanted to redeem
on me uh when i made the bitcoin
investment and i begged them to be
patient i begged them not to and then of
course anthony what happened was bitcoin
went from 65 000 to 29 000 and i have to
confess to you that the heat was on me
uh and i went over there to see people
and i said please you know
you know be patient here's how we're
thinking about this and yesterday i got
a call
from the head guy and he said you know i
just want to thank you
for bringing me into the future
i now see
what you saw
and you were bold enough to to to do
that for me and he said something
interesting i'll share with you says you
know you've got these art consultants
uh and joan whitney payson who owned the
mets
uh her daughter once said well god bless
our art consultant because there was a
there was an artist that cut his ear off
named vincent van gogh and we bought the
art for 300 000
and in 1987 we sold it for 41 million
which was a big number back in 1987 and
she was like well thank god for that art
consultant because he saw something in
that artist
that was going to manifest itself into
the future and that's what you're doing
with the best business show and that's
what you pomplianos are doing you're
showing somebody something
that's happening
and
because it's hard to believe
and i'll say something to you that it
sounds too good to be true
so they don't want to do it and when
you're an old guy like me and somebody
says well something that's too good to
be true you run you don't want to do
something that's too good to be true but
let me show you something that's too
good to be true this see it
this is too good to be true
okay that eats up the world it takes all
the
books in my library all the photographs
i've got access now to all the
information let me ask you something
would you like to roam the library
congress or have my smartphone to do a
research report what would you like to
do would you like to go to the dewey
decimal system in the library of
congress or would you like my smartphone
fully charged for the day what would you
like for years i've always thought the
dewey decimal system was stupid
yeah yeah all right but you know the
point i'm making is this phone is too
good to be true and the market
capitalization of amazon
or apple too good to be true ten
thousand dollars going to 21
million dollars in 24 years too good to
be true so this is
technical properties that are happening
before our eyes
and we either have to accept and embrace
them
uh and be willing to
propitiously allocate to them so let's
say you don't believe me or you don't
believe anthony pompliano
how about a half a percent of your
portfolio how about one percent of your
portfolio you know plan b i think you've
interviewed him pomp plan b said to me
on my podcast
if you took one cent
and you put it in bitcoin 10 years ago
and you had 99 cents in cash and that
was your asset allocation that was your
tactical asset allocation model it
outperformed everything
everything
okay so guys put a half a percent in put
put a percent in this is the early
innings of a technological revolution
where the blockchain and things like
bitcoin are going to delay the society
you know if i if i were american express
or visa i'd be worried because the
transaction speeds permitted over the
blockchain are way faster it's way
cheaper
why do i have to as a merchant accept a
three percent charge ten years from now
why will i have to do that
if everyone's got a smart wallet and a
smartphone
and uh some interac interoperability
on the internet
over the blockchain why would i have to
do that guys you're not going to have to
obviously
right well no no more you see aunt you
don't remember this you you kids are
italian kids but i'm going to set you in
1985 probably before the three of you
were born i'm waiting in rome at the
post office
to get to a phone booth
to connect to an att operator to call my
mother okay to let her know because i
could call her once a week it was three
dollars a minute i could get her on the
phone and let her know i'm okay so
waited online i got into the phone booth
18 t operator here's my credit card hi
ma i'm okay
ten dollar phone call for three minutes
fast forward we're doing this costless
over the internet right i can i can log
onto a wi-fi in an italian cafe make a
internet phone call to my mother for no
charge
that's what's going to happen to
financial services it's happening right
now okay you just happen to
be at the forefront of it i'm a little
bit farther behind from you but trust me
i'm catching up
and i'm just trying to educate my
clients that that's what's happening
okay yes i made that phone call because
that's all we could do back in 1985. but
today i can i can talk to her over zoom
costlessly
she loves you i already know i don't
even talk to her she's an italian mom
she loves you
hope to god man i renovated the house
a good italian son's supposed to do you
know what i mean i pay for the gucci you
know shoes
i hope she loves me all right uh last
group i want to talk to you about and
then i'll let you go is uh rias we saw
interactive brokers just announced that
they're gonna start letting people buy
it there's companies like on-ramp and a
bunch of other options the etf now is
available are rias can we put them all
in one big bucket they're coming they're
in they're not interested you know when
you talk to that sector what's their
status
they're scared they're scared they don't
want to miss it
um they don't understand it
um they are
in the business
of what i call it the stay wealthy
business pump you know somebody comes to
me i'm an ria
they sold their business they're wealthy
my job is to keep them wealthy right
i've got to figure out a asset mixture
that gets them out of inflation and they
can still buy art at sotheby's and i got
to put them in some private equity and
get them some growth but what i don't
want to do is make big mistakes
and embarrass myself because then
they'll fire me if i make sure that they
stay wealthy
i keep my job and i stay higher you see
what i'm saying and so they're afraid
and so
they are behind me
because
it's sort of like self-conscious
embarrassment if i put three percent of
your portfolio in bitcoin it goes from
66 000 to 10 000
and you're gonna look at me and say well
why the hell did you do that because
their clients don't really understand
bitcoin
and so they're afraid so what happened
yesterday
is transformational
because now they can go to clients and
say okay listen this is a technical
asset it is a technology that represents
a networked value and it's an evolution
on money you and i talked about that the
first time we met we had wampum we had
seashells we had cloth you know we had
uh you know this this money that we call
paper money is actually not
paper money pump this is made out of
linen okay look at this okay this is for
your viewers you know what this is
those are
those are italian singles pop you see
that
those are italian singles see those
right and because i'm old-fashioned i
always gotta have money on you never
know when you're gonna need the money to
cut and run somewhere right so look at
this this is a piece of fabric it's 75
cotton it's 25
linen
it's worthless pump you know that and i
know that
but it's got numbers on it and it's got
a an old dead white person we only have
white males on our money by the way and
we're going to trade this with each
other
why we trust this we trust that the next
guy that takes it is going to be able to
trade it for goods and services you see
what i'm saying so now what you create
is satoshi nakamoto created
is a trusted network
where we don't even have to use this
anymore we don't even have to use the
bank we can use that trusted network
that decentralized
internet highway system do you see how
brilliant that is
guys i mean i know you guys see it but
i'm trying to
impress it upon the people that are
listening to you
because you got the best business show
and they want to learn from you so i'm
trying to explain to them we're moving
from this and we're moving from a
magnetic strip known as a credit card in
your wallet
and we're moving from those electronic
digits
if i want to buy a g wagon tonight i
call chase i say wire 200 grand over to
the mercedes and the g wagon shows up
but those electronic digits are
worthless other than the fact that
they're a ledger they go down in my
account up in the mercedes-benz account
i got the g wagon all right how is the
bitcoin anything different from what i
just said in fact if anything my god
it's
audited
it's audited by a decentralized nodal
system
and it's airtight and it's a fixed
supply you tell me what i'm missing bob
you tell me what i'm missing invite
somebody on like peter schiff
who's you know tutte potts
which for the non-italians that's like a
chicken running in somebody's head he
doesn't even know what he's talking
about
you know and i'm trying to be polite to
the guy when i debate him but what are
you talking about peter
all right before i i was gonna let you
go but i gotta ask one question you
brought the g right anything anything
you want anything you want i'm i'm i'm
finally caffeinating so i'm i know i
feel like i know you guys felt that i
was a little under energized for this
thing
you're always bringing the energy what's
the craziest thing you've ever bought
like what like you just you look back
and you're like man that was nuts
all right whatever the thing you just
thought of let me just want to hear it
you gotta understand this so yeah let me
stipulate okay i'm nouveau reached
italian right my dad was a crane
operator my mother was a homemaker when
i got into harvard law school anthony my
mother thought it was hartford law
school she had no clue you know she was
like ready to take me to hartford
connecticut i'm like no ma it's in
boston but why the hell would they call
it hartford law school if it's in boston
because it's called harvard ma right i
mean that's the family i grew up in so i
had no money as a kid i started making
money
the stupidest thing i bought was the
batmobile
from the 1992
batman returns movie
starring michael keaton michelle
pfeiffer and danny devito
and i owned that for about 10 years
and i used to put the bat
outfit on and drive it around on
halloween with my kids okay and by the
way it wasn't you couldn't drive the
thing there was no license plate or
anything like that it was a it was a
prop car and i used to bottom out
everywhere in port washington when i was
driving around in it but there was a
propane tank in the back you could flip
the switch and the flames would shoot
out of the back it was it was effing
fantastic
italians italians love cars okay
so now you know now now i have the
garden variety lamborghini because i
love cars i mean what am i going to do
of course i'm going to have a
lamborghini when i was when i was a kid
i had a 1979 camaro
and someday i said yeah i'm going to
make some money and i want a lamborghini
so i eventually bought one but
about
15 16 years ago
i sold that it's now in a museum in abu
dhabi at their automotive museum but it
was a lot of fun to own it for the years
that i had it that might be the best
answer i've ever got to that question to
have the batmobile that shoots out fire
is incredible okay it was yeah it was
hooked up to a pro you had to make sure
no one hit anybody rear-ended you it was
going to be a really badass
i'll just let you know it was not it was
not
road appropriate but i did drive it
around in my hometown on halloween with
the batman outfit on yo you got to send
me a picture of you in the batman outfit
you just just gotta i gotta find you
know i gotta find them
back then we didn't have smartphones so
i have no idea where the hell these
pictures are i'd have to find them
awesome uh i've dropped your uh your
twitter account go follow anthony on uh
on twitter absolute great follow you got
a million followers by the way that is a
a big feat what did you start the year
at
well no look i you know i think that was
from the politics to be candid you know
um but uh i don't even know what i
started the year at i don't look at it
that carefully
uh but listen you know i think uh
i think you're gonna be uh the 10
million follower man before long you
know you and plan b
are going to be the two uh twitter
heroes of of bitcoin listen
i'm a little bit too political you know
i want people to get vaccinated
i i think donald trump is completely
nuts you know so i'm going to be a
little bit more opinionated than you
you forget all the politics for a second
in terms of the different parties you i
do have to say
you gave the greatest press conference
performance of all time when you hit
everyone with the finger gun
when you're in the white house i told
you this before but the kiss
kissed everybody
come on like like still to this day i
think of that and i'm like
that's
the point the point is they're asking
tough questions i'm giving them tough
answers i'm not going to sit there and
get rolled by anybody
you know and you know i i know my facts
and i'm coming to play
um and i could have helped trump but you
know i made a mistake i got myself fired
that's another big lesson for people
i never blamed my firing on anybody but
me i got myself fired i said something
which was really effing funny but
inappropriate and i got fired let's move
on general kelly and i
are great friends today he fired me he's
been to my saw conference three times
we've done public speeches around the
country together
and life moves on when you make a
mistake
the number one lesson as an investor or
a person
is forget it what are you gonna do
you're not gonna walk around with the
millstone of regret
on your neck every morning i don't wake
up in the morning and say let me kick
myself in the pants i did something
stupid that got my ass fired at the
white house four years ago
i said today's a brand new day
let's go what do you say is palm seize
the day let's get after whatever you say
every morning
that's what we gotta do
right relentlessly get after things
and be in love with life you know and if
you're taking yourself too seriously
look in the mirror relax you know what
does mel brooks say relax none of us are
getting out of here alive okay you're
not living forever i mean you may end up
in the singularity because you're
younger than me but i doubt it
so go have a glass of scotch and relax a
little too you know and buy some bitcoin
perfect
and buy some you gotta you gotta own
bitcoin bitcoin is gonna be a big part
of the future
and i hope i hope your your people are
listening to you pomp and your brothers
i uh i appreciate it very much where can
uh if people want to learn more about
skybridge where should we send them
well you know you can go obviously to
skybridge.com
you can email me i gave out my email
right it's a scaramucci
at skybridge.com i'll send you a packet
of information we can set up a call
whatever you guys want to do i i'm happy
to get these books my assistant's ready
to kill me i got all these books loaded
up in our our storage facility i'm happy
to send those out you just let me know
i'll mail i'll mail you one if you're
one of pomp's friends you're one of my
friends anthony scaramucci author of a
new york times but no i don't know new
york times but a best-selling book
because he bought them all himself
internet
pump you got to get the verbies right
this these are international i've
written five books they're all
international bestsellers
but no one other than me has ever bought
the book so you go figure out that okay
you figure out how many books i've got
in storage
you're doing a great job all right
listen thank you for taking the time to
do this i know you're busy so i
appreciate it
real pleasure to be on aunt thank you
and and guys best of luck to you guys
and i i need a hat that says bitcoin 150
joe
we're on it we're on it
all right thank you
all right bye